I was doomed from the start why does one
run towards ruin why is it hold such a
fascination
[Music]
[Applause]
appreciation has been most intelligent I
congratulate you on the success of your
performance what I'm saying is that I
have lived in the grip of ice pleasure
Oscar Wilde the centres of the cult is
that you'll be imprisoned and kept to
hard labor for two years it was wrong
and I have paid will make a classic of
you yet only unlike dear Jesus you have
luggage
I intend to effect a reconciliation with
my wife I feel sure that if I was to see
him once
it would forgive him if isn't rest
assured I should never see Lord Alfred
Douglas again I forbid him did it with
that infernal man
vodka let's run away someone no one
could find us you don't know us
then you will never see Constance again
not wearing those silk stockings today I
go too far sir thank you go too far
[Music]
[Music]
you've taken everything my family my
work my freedom everything
suffering is nothing when there is love
love is everything how does the love and
be like left but the price I pay for it
[Music]
who kind of you to speak to me you
couldn't let me fight dance could you
[Music]
I'm in mortal combat with this wallpaper
Ruby mine ever since ago
you
[Music]